this video explains how to import your
photos from a digital camera using
Picasso's new and improved import
feature first open Picassa and attach
your camera using the cable provided or
insert the memory card into a memory
card reader the import room should open
automatically select your camera or
device and decide what you'd like
Picassa to do with your photos after you
import them Picasso will acquire your
photos from your camera if you'd like to
import all your photos click import all
you can also select specific photos to
upload or use the new Star feature to
select photos you'd like to upload to
Picasso web albums you can also select
photos you'd like to exclude from import
by choosing the photo and clicking the
exclude
icon next select the location on your
computer you want to import your images
to and specify a title for the folder
the title of your folder will be the
name of the album
by default your folder title will be the
date on which you've imported the
pictures uploading photos directly to
Picassa web albums is now even easier to
upload your photos simply select the
upload option select the privacy
settings of your album and the final
size of your
photos to upload only the photos we
start earlier select the start images
only
option finally click import selected to
import the photos you've selected if
you'd like to import all of your photos
click on import all if you choose to
upload your photos to Picasso web albums
Picasso will start your upload
automatically for more information on
using Picassa please visit our help
center or help Forum The Help Center can
be found at
picasa.com
ssupport once in The Help Center you can
also visit the to help for him